an update now to a story we told you
about yesterday a Montreal area woman
says her car was stolen right before her
eyes during a test drive after listing
it on sale on Facebook Marketplace a
2011 Audi A4 that was used in a smash
and grab in a shopping Center North of
Toronto was actually stolen in Laval
Taylor Anna cobinger says the driver
sped off when they were supposed to
switch seats the car which was damaged
has since been found kobeger says she
can't believe what happened
it hurts because I've worked very hard
to get that car
and
I had just put a lot of money into it in
order to sell it
and now everything is down the drain
just I lost everything yes the car is
there but how much is it going to cost
to fix it
that's if it's even fixable
two suspects are still being sought
police say they also robbed an
electronic store